[Musique]
mais pendant la guerre j'ai caché après
au ce rare témoignage de barbara aux
répétitions à châteauroux a été
recueilli par gérard vergès pour son
film barbara ma plus belle histoire
d'amour
sylvie et yves bordeaux la chanteuse y
évoque sa petite enfance et sa vie
d'avant l'immense vedette qu'elle est
devenue dans les années 70 et révèle
qu'elle a vécu à deux reprises en larmes
quand il a été attaqué dans la plaine de
châtillon trouve son père ça n'était pas
mais moi j'ai dès l'entrée un mois je
connais très bien votre région
[Musique]
la petite fille est née dans le wagon
cap a été nul
le proto nord où se dresse en juin 1940
comme des millions de français de
barbara qui n'a que 10 ans se retrouvent
sur les routes de l'exode par le bois du
par sa mère en poste à la préfecture de
blois a eu vent de la coupure défaut sur
la loire avec sa tante et son frère et g
dans un train arrêté en rase campagne à
châtillon-sur-indre les occupants
camperont une quinzaine de jours
attendant une hypothétique locomotive et
les wagons seront bombardés par les
allemands elle fera partie des rescapés
est accueilli dans le village de près ou
dans l'indre
d'abord hébergé dans l'école communale
elle trouve refuge avec sa tante et son
frère dans un des établissements du
village le café lanchais qui dispose de
quatre chambres à l'étagé le bâtiment
existe toujours
situé face à l'église son propriétaire
nous a ouvert ses portes et la forme ou
de barbara se situe ici avec une
ouverture de toit sur la rue et une
ouverture sur l'arrière et comme vous le
voyez fait en mauvais état c'est à
restaurer en totalité dans la courtoisie
au fond du jardin de la tuilerie
attenante au café lanchais une petite
maison aujourd'hui désaffectée en 1940
elle abritait la famille d'origine à 77
ans plus tard cette dernière a tenu à
témoigner sur les lieux mêmes où petite
fille de 11 ans elle jouait
quotidiennement avec celles qui ne
s'appelait pas encore barbara mais
monique serre et qui du haut de ses 10
ans affirme et déjà qui voulait
l'entendre son intention d'être une
artiste donc on s'amusait à jouer tout
ça et on est
j'avais un petit piano l'arrêt des
jouets de ses
de rémy la perdrix mi fa sol et en vol
famille rey dans un pré il ya les deux
tombent dans l'eau voilà du coup des
lois obsédant du mal de rente menthe
verte ou une petite cantate comme nous
jouions autrefois ça le jeu l'ajout
maladroite similaires et salle d'eau
c'est tout mais ne leur est celle
enchaîne alors amené la cour
c'était là ça faisait la cour alors
tiana une autre jacqueline leclercq qui
menait si on se retrouvait donc sans
jouer nous avons également retrouvé
jacqueline installé depuis les années 70
à châtillon-sur-indre à une dizaine de
kilomètres de près où tous ces souvenirs
sont dans sa tête car nul photos de
barbara même de classe témoigne de cette
époque la barre elle venait pratiquement
tous les jours à la maison
enfin l'été plus plus proche de ce côté
là pour jouer avec les gina parce qu'il
était la même pour l'heure naturellement
moi il y avait un petit peu de
différence pour enfournement fait un peu
par contre quand tu as avec mon père
allait à la ferme aigles cheval avec l
âme alors à l'humidité
bébel parce qu on l'appelait bébel alors
la plaie mais belle tu prochaine alors
il a fait mustapha ce cheval alors
aparté avec lui alors qu'elle était
heureuse comme tout jeu partir là mais
s'il où on va elle chantait beaucoup
alors à l'école c'était madame longuet
qui nous faisait les cours elle était
dans la classe inférieure mais n'empêche
pour les t3 qu'on avait des mois c'est
vrai que j'aurais pu la suivre
bon bref elle disait déjà cette
époque-là par glu je suis chanteuse
willow fallait pas que le guide on
s'attend parce qu'alors là
elle voulait pas d'une seule bombe dans
sa famille j'aimais mon dos nu à l'école
normale donner des coups comme autant de
mon enfance et longtemps j'ai fermé les
yeux je crois que je priais je
retrouvais mon innocence heures avant
que le soir de pause j'ai voulu voir
maisons fleuries sous les roses j'ai
voulu voir le jardin à la mairie de
préaux malgré des recherches dans les
registres le nom de monique sert
n'apparaît pas même dans celui de
l'école
une précaution peut-être pour protéger
la petite fille juive et sa famille
apparemment on n'a pas de trace vraiment
écrit tuer tout le monde le sait tout le
monde tous les anciens qui sont encore
de ce monde là où l'on connu sur la
l'école avec elle il ya plusieurs
personnes qui sont fils l'ont fréquentée
qui elle est qui ont joué avec elle mais
et laissez passer incognito sur les sur
les dossiers est toujours temps arrive
après on m'a finalement rien n'indique
jusque là rien fait
conseil municipal et moi envisageons de
faire imposer une plaque commémorative
comme quoi la vécu un peu plus d'un an
et sur le mettre sur le bâtiment
adéquate sur parce qu'il existe toujours
une chance est vrai que la personne
n'est propriétaire jouent le jeu puis a
envie de faire revivre la situation il
aura fallu que l'association locale art
et savoir faire héberger dans l'ancien
café lanchais pour son exposition
annuelle décide de rendre hommage à
barbara pour que l'histoire de la
chanteuse recommencent à se répandre
hors de la commune en cette année de
commémoration des 20 ans de sa
disparition
james allard n'est pas étranger à cette
renaissance le propriétaire a entrepris
la rénovation du lieu
aimerait y associer la mémoire de la
chanteuse le projet final n'est pas figé
cependant j'entends bien restauré la
totalité si possible de cette bâtisse
envisager la restauration et sujet serré
de renouveler la chambre de barbara non
pas avec le mobilier qu'elle a connue
parce qu'il a disparu depuis longtemps
mais avec du mobilier d'époque et
peut-être que je ne pense pas l'année
prochaine mais les années suivantes
lorsqu'on fera l'exposition peinture on
aura j'espère la possibilité d'accéder à
l'étagé et que les visiteurs puissent
aller jusqu'à dans la chambre
qu'occupait barbara ya un si la chambre
de barbara enfants a disparu
celle où jeune femme de 27 ans elle
réside à plus de six mois
existe toujours à quelques encablures de
là à la sortie de buzançais chez iw et
sylvie du manoir notez-le évoqué les
noms dans la séquence du film le seul
homme oiseau l'a vu dans le sait c'est
loin c'est un château du bois rhône
sylvie et bordeaux opération en juin
dix sept ans après son premier séjour
dans l'indre barbara débarque avec son
amoureux de l'époque jean poissonnier
dit toto au château de boiro nos amis de
longue date du propriétaire il est venu
pour trouver refuge et travail
barbara pour mettre au point son tour de
chant la suite sylvie nous la raconte
il n'avait pas fous ils sont venus tous
les deux ici et elles pour faire son
piano elle faisait un piano tous les
jours tous mes joueurs
c'est là qu'elle a appris son métier
enfin tout est dit comment comme comme
jeune femme s'était du jeune femme
guéant jouer on paie très dangereux elle
faisait plein de bêtises
elle adorait ça c'est difficile à dire
quand même par exemple longtemps et se
précipiter les et j'ai faim puis halal
erlach la soupe des chiens enfin la
mangez pas beaucoup d'arrivées
elle prenait appelle la soupe du chien
tellement jolie quand c'est vrai
la rai 2
savons pas du tout de sa vie antérieure
et comme elle a été très discrets n'en
parlez pas tous les jours elle venait
dans cette pièce qui n'étaient pas
habitées il est juste le piano et puis
des meubles très chic et dans le froid
le plus total de chaux et dans le froid
après parce qu'elle restait jusque
jusqu'au mois de janvier les parties
monstres divers mon mari et moi alors
ils sont partis et à la bi a fait parce
que c'est là que fait elle a été tout de
suite à lécluse
une autre électeur que c'est grâce à
vous qu elle a eu sa première vraie robe
de scène est ce que c'est exact c'est
mon mari qui l'a qui leur donnait ça
quand ils sont partis plus acheté sa
robe de scène
[Musique]
un pépin
yves et sylvie reverrons barbara en
allant à ses concerts elle reviendra une
fois à boire au no avec l'amour de sa
vie vers baylet qui lui inspira ce
célèbre chanson dis quand reviendras tu
sylvie décidera de faire chambres
d'hôtes dans les années 85 sur le site
internet l'histoire de barbara figure
aux côtés de celle d'yves du manoir
rugbyman de légende et oncle de son mari
aujourd'hui ce sont ces petits enfants
qui accueille la clientèle qui a le
privilège de dormir là où barbara vécu
six mois
j'aime bien certains vieux chanteur
j'aime bien des vieilles chansons je
connais pas très bien barbare année mais
temps en temps j'aime bien ça me plaît
mais sinon ça évoque rien de rien de
personnel j'ai entendu cette histoire de
ma grand-mère est donc tout ça j'aurais
entendu parler mais évidemment je n'ai
pas rencontré
donc pour moi c'est assez waltary vague
mais je trouve ça rigolo parce que oui
ça me plaît me plaît comme chanteuse
donc c'est rigolo de se dire qu'elle
était un petit précis même si de la
fenêtre de la chambre
on aperçoit le parc et le silo de la
ferme où travaillait totaux que rien n'a
changé ou presque des paysages que
barbara a pu voir lors de son séjour le
temps file inexorablement peut-être un
peu moins vite dans l'indre où dans ces
deux lieux
on peut toujours retrouver sa trace
mais fort bien de retour au moins le
situe le volcan qui prend le temps perdu
ne heurteront ne se rattrapent les seuls
[Musique]